i still hate intros fire force part two
episode 13.
we're still talking about the flashback
where conroe got so injured fourth
company shows up after the incident was
over and because of their actions they
want to induct shin moon and conroe into
their ranks and form the seventh company
conroe is able to convince shimon to
join because if they had proper
equipment for the incident it wouldn't
have gone so badly shinmon still doesn't
really get along too well with the
empire though because he was expecting
them to get there earlier
back on up to the present where it turns
out they weren't the only case of
mistaken identity but there are actually
numerous misunderstandings causing
mayhem
all over the town even one of the twins
is being impersonated by somebody else
luckily arthur is around to drop the
little figure revealing that it's
actually an
old man we then get a look at the one
responsible for the doppelgangers
a white clad member named yona him along
with the other white clad members from
before
arrow and haron put their plan into
action to kill 8th company
everyone has to take cover as they start
taking fire from arrows so shinra and
arthur try to pinpoint where the shots
are coming from
meanwhile conroe interrogates the old
man to find out where the real hikage is
but he transforms himself into an
infernal forcing them to kill him shinra
and arthur catch up and get into a fight
with arrow and haron
for the first time the two have to put
aside their differences in an attempt to
match the white clad's teamwork once
they start getting the upper hand haron
tells arrow to run
and that he's gonna buy her some time he
then eats one of the infernal bugs
hoping to get a little bit stronger to
hold off the two
yeah episode 14. the people of the
district are all fighting amongst
themselves and everything is in complete
disarray
shimon then rallies the people around
him and tells him all to start attacking
each other which seems like a dumb
[ __ ] idea i guess the logic is that
if they're attacking somebody then it's
a 50 50 that they're actually attacking
a doppelganger meanwhile hurran had
turned into a special infernal called a
demon with the demon's horns it bears a
striking resemblance to what had
attacked shinra's family when he was a
child the demon proves to be too much
for the kids to handle luckily shimon
shows up to fight it instead
shimon then flies up into the sky with
the demon to blow it up with a massive
blast so that everybody else nearby
isn't injured arrow sees this happening
so she launches an attack at them in
order to stop him
we then see that shinro's flames have
some sort of sense that is able to
perceive conroe's cries for help
this alerts him to the imminent danger
that shinon is in and he is able to fly
up and stop the shot from connecting
this allows shimon to use his crimson
moon ability which causes a massive
explosion and kills the demon
episode 15. arrow and yonah are about
the part of the knights of the ashen
flame and
answer to shinra's little brother in
show show plans to win shinra over to
their side since his edola burst would
be too valuable to waste
over to the eighth company where we
learned that victor will be joining them
to work as the company's head scientist
the company is in need of an engineer
too
so shinra iris and arthur are sent to
convince a potential candidate for the
job named
vulcan to join the company also they go
to meet with the candidate but he
clearly isn't a fan of the fire force
and wants nothing to do with them he's
kind of stonewalling them so instead
they go to talk with you who is vulcan's
apprentice
aaron boy they're able to convince you
that they're a lot different from the
other companies so he agrees to let them
in
and we finally meet the engineer vulcan
wilkin is in pretty high demand because
other companies along with hajime
industries have all
offered him jobs hajima industries
aren't too happy with the fact that he
refused their offers so they turn all of
the merchants against him now he can't
get any new parts
also a part of vulcan's ragtag crew is
the sexy ginger
lisa obviously lisa's gonna be in the
running for the waifu candidates but
she's still heart stuck
second because we can grope tamaki
without any repercussions
suck it ginger anyways they don't get to
talk to vulcan at all because third
company's captain giovanni shows up and
vulcan goes outside to talk with him we
learned that giovanni is working with
hajima and is the one that cut him off
from the merchants
he goes on to threaten vulcan with more
severe consequences unless he joins
hajima vulcan refuses because obviously
he doesn't want to work for somebody
like that and then as soon as he goes
inside shinra has a sales pitch of his
own
this somehow segues into vulcan sharing
a dream to create a new better source of
energy that can replace amaterasu and
bring back all the species that have
gotten extinct but literally nobody
asked bottom line though he doesn't want
to work with them they then hear from
you that both vulcan's father and
grandfather
had both went infernal at the same time
vulcan of course suspects that giovanni
was behind it because he was the only
other apprentice to vulcan's grandfather
as soon as the two died giovanni went to
work with hajima which was forbidden by
their master because of some history
shinro's infernal sense starts tingling
again when he picks up on giovanni's
bloodlust
episode 16. giovanni is revealed to be
working with the white clad and he sends
two members called mirage
and flail to kill vulcan general was
keeping the lookout for trouble and is
attacked by giovanni he
electrocutes shimra in order to take him
to evangelist and convert him to their
side
in preparation for their fight we
learned that the more arthur feels like
a knight the stronger he
is with this in mind vulcan gives him a
makeshift cape and straps a horse's head
to his dick arthur kind of feels like a
badass though so his power starts to
grow exponentially
that is until mirage's glimmers which is
like an illusion thing makes him realize
how [ __ ] stupid he looks
his power drops off after that but he
still tries to fight him we also get a
quick side note that vulcan's family was
actually the one that designed the
amaterasu that's not all we learned
though as the ginger bay lisa is
revealed to be a third generation
working for the evangelist she attacks
vulcan
in order to force him to give her some
sort of key to the amaterasu giovanni
shows up soon after in search of the key
also
it was apparently hidden by vulcan's
grandfather and vulcan has no idea what
they're talking about giovanni thinks
he's lying so he shoots you
and says that he's gonna die unless
vulcan gives him the key
episode 17. hibana had apparently
planted a wire in iris heard the
commotion goes looking for shinra and
sets him free just as giovanni located
the key shinra makes his entrance and
knees him in the face
arthur's getting help from hibana to
deal with the white clad members while
shinra gets subdued by lisa
vulcan helps him get free using his
creations but hibana gets knocked
unconscious as collateral shinra fights
back now that he's free but when the
fight ends up outside he comes face to
face with his brother
even though he believes shinra is his
brother he still uses his power to
defeat both him and arthur sho secures
the key to
matarasu but shinra and arthur are
rescued by victor who uses his explosive
ashes to cause a distraction
we see lisa is having second thoughts
about joining them but then decides
against it in the last second
again show uses his power and gets ahead
of their truck this is when joker
intervenes and manages to keep up with
show's movements long enough to secure
the other's escape yu is then rushed to
the hospital and everybody survives the
ordeal
after that vulcan takes shinra up on an
offer to stay at 8th company but just as
a guest for safety however while talking
obi is able to win vulcan over and he
ends up joining 8th company as their new
engineer
episode 18. hibana kareem and conroe
show up at 8th company to compare notes
on the evangelist they decide that they
need to find the evangelist's base and
hit them directly
well victor is out looking for new clues
on where the white clad could be hiding
he runs into joker
joker is wanting him to find a new way
to upgrade shinra's abilities because at
this rate he's never going to be able to
keep up with show
conroe also phones in some help from
shimon to train the rookies giving them
a little bit more combat experience
shinra and arthur are sent to train with
him while vulcan
is hard at work making new tools for 8th
company while training victor makes the
observation that when shinra uses his
flames they kind of go all over the
place the punchline is that if he can
learn how to condense his flames to
shoot it in one direction that should
give him a nice speed boost
back on over to vulcan who had made twin
hover units called techio which are
pretty much flying hammers that maki can
control using her 2nd gen powers
meanwhile shinra tries emulating hand
motions that he saw shimon
using to control his flame jin mon
notices him doing this and tells him
that it's called
kata which was commonly used by martial
artists of old japan
one of them is called tiger crusher
which channels power to the user's feet
when shinra bends both his index finger
and thumb
inward it condenses his flame just like
he was wanting
episode 19. 8th company learns that the
white clad members are hiding in what's
called the nether which is a series of
abandoned subway tunnels the next day
8th company goes into the nether to
launch an attack on the evangelist
followers
once inside the team is attacked and
separated by white cloud using smoke
screens
iris gets stuck with tamaki and an
imposter posing as her she can't find
out which one's real because she's
stupid
until tamaki's bad luck kicks in and she
defies all logic to get randomly
stripped
this confirms that she is the real
tamaki and then the imposter just walks
off
shortly after he's gone they are
confronted by their first threat in
assault over damaki who is targeted by
flails so she uses her new toys to fight
back taking down him and all of his
subordinates
and then we hop back on over to iris and
tamaki who engages seoul and to no one
surprised quickly start losing the
maki's bad luck continues and this
creates an opening for iris who bashes
assault over the head with a pipe
followed by an overkill beatdown
episode 20. we see that hinawa is
encountered by arrow and the two
exchange shots between one another
meanwhile
victor was captured by a no-name yclat's
eye character and he gets one shot by
shinrug using his new hand signals
back to hinawa who needs to close the
distance on arrow because he can't even
see where she's shooting from so he
starts to move through the subway cars
this only ends up trapping him and she
gets off an easy shot injuring him in
the process
you're using his power he now starts
amping up all of his shots creating
massive shock waves
the only drawback to this skill is that
he has to replace his gun barrel after
every shot because it's so powerful that
it gets destroyed he now
is now pretty spent after exchanging so
many shots with arrow he
rallies just enough to get one last shot
off using her flames to accelerate the
bullet even more
this results in him finally landing the
finishing blow and defeating arrow
even though he won he is completely out
of energy when yona and mirage approach
him
arthur then makes his entrance to get
his rematch with mirage and save hinawa
thanks to his training with konro and
shimon he is now able to see through the
shimmers that mirage was creating
using his glimmers as a distraction
mirage moves in to kill hinawa arthur
picks up on his presence as he
approaches allowing him to kill mirage
through a concrete pillar wilkin and obi
wound up together and as they're
searching for others they conveniently
run into the conniving but still hot
ginger hard stuck second place waifu
lisa and of course her sugar daddy
giovanni
it becomes clear that giovanni is
manipulating lisa to fight for him even
though she doesn't really want to but
she isn't sure how to say no to daddy
episode 21. obi and bulkan are both at
lisa's mercy since neither of them have
powers to fight back against her they
try to get through to her but she
doesn't seem to be willing to listen so
obi takes some hits in order to place
extinguisher grenades beneath her we
learned that she feels so obligated to
answer to giovanni because he was the
one that saved her as a kid kind of a
shitty father figure though because as
soon as she gives him an opening
giovanni takes her hostage
he threatens to kill her unless vulcan
shoots and kills obie
good guy obi tells him to do it in order
to save lisa so vulcan shoots him in the
chest
giovanni lets lisa go and falls for the
trap because it turns out obi was
wearing a ballistic vest that vulcan had
made for him which saved his life
who doesn't know that you have to force
the person to shoot the other person in
the face if you're gonna have somebody
kill somebody you have to know these
things
book can equip some sort of penguin mask
to fight and secure lisa
meanwhile shinra isn't looking so hot
and starts hallucinating a series of
cryptic visions
once he snaps out of it he can see
footprints leading him somewhere
ooby also learns from giovanni that
shinra is going to start getting
stronger because of his link with show
he also says that the edola burst is
what creates the infernals but doesn't
bother elaborating
anyways shinra comes face to face with
show and the two instantly start
fighting
even though he's keeping up much better
this time around shinra still can't
counter shows power that allows him to
stop time
this allows show to get the upper hand
and he lands a severe shot on shinra
giovanni's goal was to get shin red a
show and now that he has accomplished
that he calmly walks away while ob
stands there and doesn't do anything
even after he had threatened lisa's life
she still seems reliant on giovanni and
begs him to take her with him
because he's not interested so he just
leaves her with vulcan and ob
joe then transports himself and shinra
to some other dimension in the last
scene
yeah episode 22 we see yonah talking
about how shinra
is with show now just as the evangelist
had predicted we then meet yet
another white cloud member in hamea sho
talks with shinra
and explains that the dimension they are
in is where the adult burst came from
and was never
meant for their world the world is known
as the underworld edola
or better known to them as hell shinra
gets his first look at evangelist who
appears behind show but then the two are
suddenly back in the real world
we learned that show is able to steal
heat from the rest of the universe and
as it cools the universe's expansion
slows down which is how he makes time
stop shinra speculates that show is able
to do this using his adola link and if
he can utilize the same link then he
might be able to match him
after a couple of failed attempts shinra
eventually moves fast enough to make
himself disappear from show's frozen
world we get a random look at first
company where a new face comes out of
retirement to rejoin the company and the
lieutenant priests third generation on
yongo
random scene over and we're back at show
who reaches his limit and is forced to
let time resume where he sees shinra
appear and smashes into a wall he was
going so fast that he wasn't able to
control it and when he uses his speed
the second time again he smashes into a
wall
victor comes in to analyze the situation
and states that when a body meets a
certain threshold of speed it falls
apart
if it travels even faster than that it
could break down to the level of
invisible particles but if that's what's
happening somebody shouldn't be able to
reassemble themselves after that
theoretically though using the power of
an edola burst reassembling a body could
be possible
joe freezes the world before shinra can
move again but is suddenly struck by
shinra while
in his world both show and shinra bounce
in and out of real time while fighting
which push shimmer to his limit and he
collapses
during the lull in the combat victor
explains that shinra is using his flames
to accelerate to the speed of light and
that's how he's been stopping time
this tears up his body and breaks it
into subatomic particles then by
accelerating past the speed of light
those particles go back
in time and that's how he's been
reforming himself he warns that if
shinra overheats in the middle of that
process then he'll actually die
episode 23 shinra goes past the speed of
light and back in time while linking
show to his memories showing him
how much shinra cared about him and
their mom joe breaks down crying and
sheen receives his opportunity to close
the distance and give him some brotherly
love
although when they get back to real time
shinra had lost control of his speed and
accidentally impaled himself on sho's
sword um
makes her reappearance and tells him
that they are collecting a dollar burst
to create a new cataclysm and destroy
the world which we kind of already knew
her power allows her to mind control her
victims which she uses on show to force
his cooperation
arthur and the rest of eighth company
make it just in time to save shinra from
being taken by haumea thanks to arthur's
plasma sword haumea can't use her powers
properly
out of nowhere an earthquake starts
happening forcing the white clad members
and eighth company to retreat before the
nether collapses
in on them shinra is still a tad bit
injured so they have to rush him to
special fire hospital six where the six
companies captain kyoko huang will
operate on him she uses her rod of a
sapious ability to aid in his healing
and he wakes up three days later first
company's captain burns then comes to
talk with him about the fire that
happened 12 years ago
burns goes on to admit to knowing that
show had been taken by the evangelist
and withheld the information from shinra
shinro demands an explanation but burns
wants him to prove himself with a fight
before he shares it
episode 24. during the duel it's pretty
obvious that burns is still quite a bit
stronger than shinra
regardless shinra keeps fighting until
he breaks through his defenses landing a
blow on burns's arm
this proves to burns that he is now
strong enough to hear the truth so he
tells him that the evangelist has been
active for around 12 years
white clad members were sent to retrieve
sho because they knew he had an adult
burst when show's powers were awakened
he caused the house to go up in flames
shinra's mother sees the baby surrounded
by the fire and then she transforms into
a demon infernal
joe's edola burst also caused shinra's
ability to be activated as well
propelling him from the flames we then
see that the evangelist was at the
house and show's mom makes the mistake
of looking at her this causes her eyes
to burst into flames
baby haumea and another new face in
sharon are nearby and reveal that this
is why all of the white clad members
cover their eyes
in response to her now burning eyes
shows mom forces her horns down
covering her eyes with them burns
arrived 15 minutes after the fire had
started and retrieved shinra who was
right by the front door homea then uses
her power to control show's mom and make
her escape from burns with
baby show burns is able to recognize the
edola burst
and the edola link he too had also lost
his right eye in a prior incident when
he saw the adola world's flames
burns lies to shinra saying that his
mother and show were both killed so that
shinra would hate the flames and never
use his powers
by doing this the evangelist would never
find out about his edola burst and come
looking for him too
shinra realizes that when he was in the
nether he had seen his mother's demon
with the horns over her eyes this leads
him to believe that she might be alive
and maybe he can find her and turn her
back into a human
shinra also recalls seeing the captain
of fourth company soichiro hagee and
adola too
conveniently segwaying into the
introduction of soyuz granddaughter
asiko ark shinra then goes on to request
that asako introduce him to her
grandfather which she agrees to i'm
gonna be doing the future seasons and
you can find that in the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the fire force recaps in
the playlist on the right side you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing i hate more
than intros is outros